bonjour c'est virginie et bonjour c'est
l'ex mme woods nous sommes au doublage
de transfert et on a les crocs c'est
l'hôtel transylvanie de nos amis monstre
leçon là les monstres ils ont été élevés
dans le culte de les humains ne sont
mauvais pour nous en fait ils sont
plutôt ils sont plutôt gentils c'est
vraiment immonde là dedans
j'adore les méchants les méchants va
tout l'imaginaire sur ceux qui nous font
peur ont l'impression qu'ils sont sous
notre lit quand on est enfant ou cachés
dans l'armoire et qu'en fait ils ont une
humanité très très forte et que excès
nous en fait les les horribles
depuis que les venues au monde j'ai
voulu protéger ma petite fille alors
gicler un endroit où tous les monstres
serait à l'abri loin d'elle elle est
super mais vis c'est son père ce dracula
c'est la feed back et là je suis un
humain tend tout doute nuire je lui
dirai juste
elle est entourée d'amour par son père
tout ça là un grand désir d'indépendance
je veux partir découvrir le monde tu et
orange et 118 ans je te signal ne fais
pas ta tête de veau pire battus bah oui
elle vole ça c'est chouette
et bien c'est paradoxal parce que il ne
te laisse pas volés étaient proposés le
portant envie d'écouter quoi j'étais sûr
que tu allais dire ça mais papa je vis
ta parole et tu sais que je sais que la
parole d'un dracula et ça crie que la
confiance est le coeur de l'autre qu'est
ce que tu as dit je t'ai dit que c'était
d'accord encore une de tes blagues
j'ai fait quelques doublages et hossa
j'ai toujours aimé les personnages que
je t'aime et je me sentais pas forcément
proche
je sais pas s'il me ressemble mais je me
sens très proche ouais ouais je lis déjà
flatteur je m'appelle casio j'ai
quelqu'un là haut qui charvet qui
attention c'est bien tu as de la chance
tu auras toujours une jolie blanc l'a t
cotation mais je ne me déplacerai 100
belge blonde c'est un peu ça fonctionne
mais c'est pas mal en même temps et
coûte peut-être que vous avancez à se
tenir pour l'instant ça va franchement
ça va je le je vais bien je vais bien je
m'appelle frankenstein je crois pas un
francophone c'est mon oncle je suis de
la tenant en moins rouillé et en moins
bleu ça c'était tout sauf pas tu sais ce
que c'est être fun vraiment droite c'est
un peu tout l'inversé de mavis hier que
lui c'est un grand baroudeur et il va se
promener partout et là il a vu des gens
qui brûlait dehors et qui rentre au
château il a trouvé ça super cool et se
dit qu'est ce que c'est que ce château
comment tout trouvé cet endroit je
faisais de l' escalade avec quelques
potes et j'ai entendu parler d'un
château mortels d'ailleurs aux bornes
mortels jet 4 le jury est une tuerie
billy crois que c'est une soirée
costumée tous ces monstres évidemment du
loup garou à dracula et compagnie croit
que c'est pour rigoler quoi et même
quand il découvre que c'est vrai il a
peur mais enfin ça dure deux minutes
quoi président juste c'est super cool
wouah et puis surtout il la voit et dès
qu'ils voient ma vie c'est le zing enfin
les i
c'est comme ça c'est c'est l'amour fou
tu crois qu'on peut réussir et de
s'embrasser je crois qu'on peut bomber
ou haiping paf je fais du brut
waouh
comment tu t'appelles je matais 2010 la
fille de dracula c'est très joyeux de
participer même un peu à quelque chose
qu'on estime c'est drôle ça dit des
choses et l'idée géniale
enfin l'idée d'avoir tous les monstres
au il est incroyable c'est celle qui
réunit comme ça toutes nos peurs
ancestrales
j'aurais peut-être un peu plus à moi
contre moi je l'admets batouala fait
dracula tempère commence vraiment à même
et ça lui ôtait transylvanie laiterie
gayton comte dracula
voilà parce que le comte dracula voilà